you should never put yourself in a
position that in the interview it's the
first time that you're thinking about
these things and on the spot you need to
come up with a story that happened in
the past that addresses the question
that you are asked if this happens then
you were clearly not well prepared and
the likelihood is pretty high that you
will not be able to just on the spot
come up with the best story to tell in
these instances therefore what you
absolutely need to do as a preparation
to this interview come up with at least
five stories that you could tell to
answer questions like that and prepare
these stories come up with a basic
structure about how you want to go about
telling these stories